hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
host genome analysis of structural
variations
by optical genome mapping in patients
with severe covid19
i am jennifer woods of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you
by bio nano genomics to learn more
visit bionanogenomics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
ravindra kohlhe
vice chair of pathology and section
chief of molecular and genetic pathology
and director of georgia esoteric and
molecular lab
augusta university and nikhil
sahaj paul research associate
georgia esoteric and molecular lab
augusta university
dr colhay you may now begin your
presentation
thank you good morning everyone good
morning everyone my name is robbie cole
hey i'm a pathologist at the
medical college of georgia i guess
georgia
the place of masters welcome
to the seminar one what we're gonna try
to do today is present
our attempt to understand uh the
structural variance uh
in individuals who are severely affected
by covid
and and the importance and use of
pre uh
appropriate technology for something
like that which is optical genome
mapping
so these are my relevant disclosures for
the contents of today's stock most
importantly i'm employed by the state of
georgia and
the opinions which i'm presenting here
are personal and does not
reflect the opinions of my collaborators
or my employers and most importantly
this is a binary sponsored
webinar so this
any user binary product described in
this presentation maybe
may not have been cleared or approved by
fda for any applicable or any other
applicable regulatory body
so some introduction to the lab so i was
recruiting at
mcg nine for ten years ago to start the
molecular program
uh the lab which we have put together is
a clear lab
mostly we do complex esoteric
testing which has really helped us to
bring
really cool and cutting-edge
technologies
in in clinical space before i start on
today's data i want to take a step back
and and put together what we have done
for the last one year
for the covet and not just us as
individuals but as a collectively lab
medicine folk so
many of you know that uh till the end of
february last year cdc was the only
manufacturer and tester of
tdc was the only manufacturer and
uh tester of the kobe 19 in usa
and then after that uh
give me one second i think there's some
technical issue
can you see the slides moving i think
that's an issue with the slide control
okay okay you can go ahead and move this
light i think you can take a control and
move the slides and now
i have my
visual thing thank you so uh
so just to give you some background so
i'm on the slide
five uh the fda ua validation
and what we ended up doing was we
validated multiple different aspects of
uh
covet testing to help and then make sure
that
what we're trying to do was reaching a
lot
many people the validation process or
the eu evaluation process was not easy
we
me and my mom especially nikhil alan and
a couple of people in the group and
ashish we
sat together and uh
basically dissected the eua application
and and then put together a program
which really helped us
uh submit all the information to fda
it was i think a year ago march 13th
we were able to march 13th be able to
submit all the documentation
to the eua and
on on march 15 2020 we got a
letter from the fda to go ahead and
start working with this
and we went live at that particular
night and that had really helped the
region the state
and then probably the southeast united
states because we want a few labs to get
things started on that
and after that for the last one year the
lab has pretty much
transformed everything we were doing
into
something which was mostly clovert
focused
each and every aspect of the covet
testing we have worked together
and made substantial changes working
with our collaborators as well as fda
to make all those changes happen
the the biggest impact i think we were
able to put together was the
the help in supply chain constraints and
its optimization and
we pretty much worked changing from the
sample collection from the swap to
uh the way the samples were collected in
the vtm
and then most if not all this is
published now in in multiple
articles uh with the nichols
efforts and then the entire lab's effort
one of the i think the most impactful
thing we were able to put together was
use a saliva as a sample type
and i think we not only put together as
a sample type but
we're able to use and show and validate
that zlawa can be used
not only as a sample but for pooling as
well as
without rn extraction as well as a
multiplex for
looking at uh uh influenza a and b
okay with that introduction to our core
with work i want to dive into
slide 15 which basically talks about
the pandemic and what we have done to
help us understand
uh the role of structural variance in
severely affected curve individuals so
as many of you know this probably
is and will be one of the biggest
challenges at least in my lifetime in
our lifetimes
uh more than 150 million cases three
million debts
and we're still trying to struggle uh
we're still struggling to understand
what exactly
caused this differential split survival
not only in the symptoms but
also the icu the oxygen requirement
as well as the mortality in these
individuals
so this was around may of uh 20 10
20 i was talking to some of my
collaborators including alcachobay
and we were looking at in our clinics
and icu we would we would have these
hundreds and thousands of patients
or individuals who were infected were
basically absolutely
symptomatic and on the other hand we had
a small percentage of individuals
who were infected but
who are not only infected but severely
symptomatic
and and some even required oxygen uh
support and and a very few of them
uh end up dying so the idea was to
understand if there is something
in the host genome which is making all
the susceptibility
to the severity of the symptoms as well
as the mortality and outcome
of the infection because at that point
we
we knew that it was not the
vital load as usually in cases of
infections especially viral base
infection the vital load
sometimes can dictate uh symptoms and
outcome
but in star scope we know that
individuals who are having low ct values
or high vital load
were absolutely asymptomatic so
one of our hypotheses was there is
something in the host genome which is
making this
huge split survival and impact on
mortality
and this discussion led us to forming a
very organic over 19 host genome
consortium which is highly focused on
looking at structural readings because
when we are discussing this
we realized that there are multiple
aspects of these individuals
who were coming into icu have
co-morbidity especially focus on
diabetes hypertension heart failure
but many of these deaths were extremely
unexplained
reason with many explained reasons
there are there are multiple other
kobit 19 host genetic consortium we're
looking at
mainly the whole genome and
we reviewed the data and looked at their
finding and we identified some of the
challenges or limitations of those
uh consortium and the data which they
have one of the biggest
limitation was they were not able to
take the larger variants
and that basically helped us to put
together the kobit 19 structural
genome together it's a it's a global
consortium with more than 30 plus labs
uh with leadership from me and alki and
we're trying to
get as many people as as possible
involved with the
whole variety of uh expertise which are
helping us dissect this
a unique hypothesis based on
a split survival in in kobe 19.
as you can see the lamps are
all across the consortium uh there's a
global reach and many of the
labs uh are not only the u.s but
outside the u.s which are participating
the principal investigators come from
all across
the globe with a variety of expertise
uh in understanding human genome
um and then i'm very grateful that we
are able to put together this
amazing group of people who are trying
to help us dissect
this particular problem now the
objectives of
this particular consortium is
is fourfold one of the main thing we
really wanted to
do was create a global networks of lab
who are using
novel wrong long read molecule
technologies to assist the structural
variants in host genome
and then which can help us understand
these questions and again this this
this hypothesis or this interest or
question arise from
one of the major challenges whole genome
sequencing was not able to provide
based on the g was studies on the host
genome or host genetic study
the idea also was to create a global
networks of lab
to share the data to share the samples
as well as share the results and
approach in understanding this
particular
aspect of providing 19 host genome
uh the other the other objective we have
as
in in the consortium was to create a
global forum to share
all the data we have generated from
different genomic methods not just
one but multiple long-range molecules um
and and compare the data uh
help create different biomathematic
tools uh
and then different methods uh and
hopefully
make it readily available for everyone
and when we started looking at
the initial screening data one of the
things which were really
helpful to understand was the role of
the structural variance in contributing
to the host gym
host genome mostly focused on two
aspects one was the immune response
as well as the the viral replication
factors so nikhil will probably go in
detail
on the data aspect from the genome as
well as the
rna site to make that case but
the consortium has helped us to shed
light on genomic research
to search for more informative
structural variants for common
polymorphism protective genome variation
and other factors especially which can
other genomic factors that contribute to
mostly the starch growth to infection
progression and recovery
and as i said our this is a very organic
open
platform and group all this data will be
publicly available based on
individual institutes irb and and
research initiatives
and one of the other things we are
really trying to put together is
using optical genome mapping and
and i think it's very underutilized in
something which is
for something like understanding immune
response in cobit 19
and this consortium has really helped us
to put that aspect together
uh this effort is not something which i
can do on my own there's a whole group
of
people in my lab which are working day
and night
not only for the course genome
effort but also for the entire sars cove
to response
which we have in in the lab for the
region in the state
this is during some some part of
pandemic
uh the different uh members of my lab
uh who are working uh one of the main
people behind this is dr mondal which is
the lab supervisor but a lot of not also
definitely
also very well supported by dr chave and
dupont which
helped me make sure that i'm not doing
something uh
really out of the box especially when it
comes to
clinical care uh three very important
ladies in the lab
kemiya sudha and yasmin which are from
three different
groups of families but are working day
and night
to help us keep the star skill two
response up and going
but the not the least uh one of the
smartest people in the lab allen nikhill
uh pancake general actually which are
helping put together the scientific
aspect
so with that uh i would like to invite
nikhil
uh who is the driving force behind most
of the data
which you will see for the kobe 19 host
genome
we are we're able to put together a
manuscript which has focused on our
initial screening data
uh it's in in preprint uh and uh
nikhil will go over the data and then
i'll join you guys
back uh for the q a thank you you want
to take over
yes thank you so much
i will be happy to present our study
which incorporates the
analysis of structural variations by
optical genome mapping
in patients with severe covalent 90.
as dr coley already mentioned that there
are several host genome investigation
consortiums and efforts going worldwide
but all those
efforts are majorly focused on using the
sequencing variants
for analyzing the whole genome thus the
structural variations or large structure
variations
are rather undocumented
in in for the insights in covet 19
predisposition
[Music]
in general structure variants uh
including copy number variations account
for a significant proportion of
variations
among individuals
because the aim of the consortium and
the study was to investigate the host
genome of
individuals with severe kobit 19 at
level of large svs
which is 500 base pair and above
in order to identify events that might
provide insights
into the inter-individual clinical
variability
that we are seeing in these patients
infected with sarcoido
we have so far uh mapped around 100
genomes
but i would be presenting results from
the first 37 severely ill patients
these patients were recruited in the
first phase of the pandemic
and the inclusion criterias were the
patients that were
positive for sarskovi rtpcr test
and required mechanical ventilation or a
fraction of inspired oxygen
the mean age of the severely ill group
was 60
and was dominated by african-american
ethnicity
these patients had uh chronic pre
existing medical conditions and the
genomes were mapped using bionano's
sapphire system
with the hg19 genome assembly
the sapphire workflow relies primarily
upon isolation of high molecular weight
dna
and in this case the dna was isolated
from
the blood samples from these patients
once the dna is isolated the dna is
labeled
at specific six base pair motifs
the labeled dna is then loaded onto the
chip which goes into the sapphire
instrument
inside the instrument the dna molecule
linearizes
based on electrophoresis as it passes
through the micro channels
and nano channels and while it is
passing through the nano channels
the images are captured these images are
used to
formulate a dino consensus map which can
be aligned to any reference genome in
this case
a g90 and the difference in the
labels is used to call out such a
variations
and there is an additional coffee number
track which is based on
coverage
for the analysis of data once the
genomes are mapped
we use three different approaches the
first approach focused on
analyzing or identifying rare unique
structural variations
for which we did an unbiased whole
genome investigation
that did not appear in any of the
control database
the bionano genomics control database is
around 300 samples strong
and the svs were looked that were not
present in any of those structural
control samples further the structural
variations were filtered
for those svs that result that
disrupt the coding region of the gene
further only those structural variations
were interrogated
which were implicated in immune response
or infections in the literature
the second approach focused on
identifying common structural variations
for this a manually curated gene list
was identified or formulated which
included
around 850 genes which were genes that
were implicated in sars cov2 or viral
infection or immune pathways
then the structure variations
overlapping these genes of interest
were identified which also appear in
less than 20 percent of the
bionano control population
further only those structural variations
were evaluated which disrupt the coding
region of the gene
the third approach utilized a
genome-wide sv enrichment in severely
ill population
versus the control population
in this the data was enriched by
filtering the number of cases
for each gene more than two and
filtering for svs that appear in less
than 20 percent of the control
population
the top-ranked genes were identified
using odds ratio
i will go into each of these analysis
uh in the following slides
the key aspect of this analysis is
actually the rare
unique svs and we identified seven
unique rare structural variations
impacting 31 genes
the most important of these is rather
stk26
here in this slide we can see a copy
number track
where a gain in copy number
is observed whereas in the structure
variation track we can see the copy
number gain is a tandem duplication
if we see closely at sdk 26
we see that the duplication duplicates
partially
or overlaps partially the stk26 gene
which is
actually the five utr and coding exon
one
of this gene
we confirmed the structure variation
gain
by qpcr experiment with a simple dosage
experiment
where we use four controls two males and
two females
and you can see the patient with the
duplication in blue
patient 44 and two other patients which
did not
have the structural variation in black
the gain in function
is shown with the dosage gain above 1.3
interestingly stk26
is a negative regulator of the tlr
pathway
tlr pathway has been implicated in
severe kobit 19
cases with both host genome analysis and
rna-seq experiments where loss in
function of tlr-7 and tlr3 pathway has
been implicated in patients with severe
illness and rna-seq experiments have
shown that type 1 interferon response
is reduced in patients with severe
illness so sdks
26 course translationally inhibits traff
6
and inhibits the tlr pathway
to
investigate the functional relevance of
stk 26 gene
we looked at the literature and found
that
since the duplication was in the five
utr region
and coding x1 in the literature we found
that
dual 5 utrs are actually synthesized in
synthetic biology
to that result in increased transcript
and translation of the gene of interest
consistent with the hypothesis we found
that in expression studies stk 26 was
upregulated
in all the severely ill patients
compared to asymptomatics whereas the
patient having the
duplication was the one with the highest
expression
the next step we wanted to
look at the expression of especially the
sdk 26 post translational partner which
is t ref6
and we found that even trav6 is
significantly upregulated
in severely ill patients compared to
asymptomatics even downstream
irf3 was significantly upregulated and
severely ill
compared to asymptomatic
however since this interaction is at the
level
of protein if sdk-26
upregulation is inhibiting this pathway
we should see expression level changes
at the level of type 1 interference
consistent with the hypothesis we found
that
isg-15 expressions were significantly
lower in severely ill patients
compared to asymptomatics while the
patient with the
structural variation was the ones
amongst the lowest
similarly if it one expression was
significantly lower in severely ill
patients compared to asymptomatics
again the patient with the structural
variation was one amongst the lowest
so this data actually implies that
the duplication of the five utr region
led to an up regulation of the gene
expression
and this interrogation led us to this
coincidental finding where we found that
stk26 is upregulated in all severely ill
patients
but because of the structural variation
the
effect was potentiated in that patient
and
could have caused the severity in that
patient
additional evidence in the literature
comes from uh one of
the senior consortium members dr
alexander vuitton
who had shown previously that a loss of
function of tlr7
variant led to reduced type 1 interferon
response and was associated with
severe covalent 19. most recently
a jiva study from an italian consortium
showed
that a loss in function of sdk 26
variant is associated with protection in
males
which is again supportive to our
hypothesis where
we have found gain in function with
severity and they had found
loss in function with protection
coming to the second structural
variation this is a
heterozygous deletion of chromosome 2
that partially deletes
dpv4 gene if we
see more closely we can see that these
three labels are deleted in the bio nano
map
and they actually overlap three exons
so the deletion over the three exons
were confirmed by
qpcr dosage experiment where you can see
that
the patient 38 which is the one which
harbors this
sv the dosage drops to 0.5 for both exon
3 4 and 5.
now dpp 4 is a membrane-bound receptor
and is actually the receptor for mers
entry into the cell however the cell
line experiments have shown us that
it does not serve as a receptor for
viral entry for sarsko v2
so what additional function does this
receptor have
many of the cleavage enzymes such as
matrix metalloproteinases cleave this
enzyme
and the dpp4 exists as a soluble form in
the circulation as
sdp before and has several immune
effects such as t cell activation
so we measured using elisa the soluble
dp4 levels in the
serum of severely ill patients and
compared with asymptomatics
and found that the soluble dp4 levels
are down regulated or reduced
in the civilian patients but especially
if you can see the case 38
which is the patient with the structural
variation
the level is significantly lower as
compared to even
other severely ill patients
the additional support to our finding
comes from another
published report where
this group had also shown that the
soluble dp4 levels were reduced
in severely alkaline 19 patients but
they also showed
that the effect was specific for sars
kobe 2
that the soluble dp fluid levels do not
reduce
in patients with sepsis or other
infection
the third sv is a heterozygous
deletion of chromosome 16 that contains
six genes
most important of which is the gene
zdhc1
again the structural variation was
confirmed using qpcr
dosage experiment and you can see the
dosage dropped to 0.5 for the patient
with the structural variation
vdh c1 is again implicated in type 1
interferon response
where it stabilizes by a
post-translational modification of
if it m3 if it m3 guides
the endosomes and stabilizes the
endosomes to lysosomes
so that it impedes the viral replication
a deletion of zdhs c1
would uh can be hypothesized as a loss
in function
and does a loss of this
hypothesis and this pathway
the next structural variation is a
duplication of chromosome 17
that includes two genes krt-15
and krt19 again the structural variation
was confirmed with
qpcr dosage experiment where we can see
the
dosage gain on the patient with the
structural variation
the krt 15 and krt19
are cytokines that are bound
at the cellular junction and they
enable the viral transmission through
uh cell to cell viral transmission so
a gain of the entire gene of krt 15
and krt 19 would
rather can be hypothesized as a gain in
function
and would predispose to higher celtra
cell to cell viral transmission
the next structure variation is a
duplication of chromosome 17 that
includes 15 genes
most important of which are the cd 300
cluster
of genes
again the structure variation was
confirmed by qpcr doses
experiment what is interesting is that
cd 300 are immune receptors
on immune cells and
these have been exploited by the virus
to evade
host defense and
help in viral replication so a
duplication of the entire region
leads to can be hypothesized as again in
function
and thus helping the virus to evade the
host
defense and leading to violent
replication
and thus leading to severity in these
patients
the the next structural variation is a
duplication of chromosome 19
that includes the entire znf 443 gene
this is actually a very interesting gene
uh this is one of the genes which has
a sequence homology to star score v2
and the homologous
sequence genes have been shown to
help the virus to evade the host genome
immune response and help in viral
replication
again the duplication was confirmed by
qpcr dosage experiment where we can see
the
the the gain in dosage of the patient 13
which has the duplication where the
dosage goes to a dosage of two
the next structural variation is a
duplication
of chromosome 1 partially disrupting two
genes which include adorad gene
again although a duplication
of an entire gene can be correlated with
again in function
but here we see that the duplication is
disrupting this gene where the
duplication event starts
from intron four and duplicate six zone
five
and six
again the duplication was confirmed by
qpcr experiment
and the this unique event was identified
in two patients so edward
jean is a
promoter of nf kappa v which is an
import important
immune player that helps
in has several
responses which includes antiviral
response
so these were the seven unique rare
structure variations
that we identified in this investigation
so far
the next aspect of the analysis was
identifying common structure variations
these include
four structural variations that impacts
six
genes the first structural variation
is an inversion of chromosome 3 that
disrupts the mu4 gene
interestingly mucin genes are
the genes that produce mucus and they
are the first line of defense
against an invading pathogen so the
mucus entraps
the virus and through the mucociliary
function expulse the virus and
the t third class of mucins which
includes
muc4 uh elicit the first
immune response against those virus in
the epithelia
so the disruption of muc4
only can be hypothesized to lead to loss
in function
and in literature there is extensive
documentation that
loss of muk4 or null muc4 mice
exposed to different viruses including
sarsko v2
lead to severe lung infection
pneumonia and death
so this mu4
structural variation inversion was over
represented
in our cohort which
which uh supports that this structure
variation is implicated
in severe disease
the second common structure variation is
a duplication of chromosome 17
which includes the tcl
sorry uh ccl 3 l1 and ccl4
l2 gene interestingly this duplication
is in the cnvr region the coffee number
variable region and the
the coordinates vary for different
individuals but they
always almost include both these genes
the structure variation in all these
patients were confirmed by qpcr and you
can see the different dosage as
the as it is a copy number variable
region
the ccl genes are actually immune genes
and
inflammatory genes so
in literature uh the in severely ill
coven 19 patients we have found that
the ccl 3 l1 and ccl4 l2
genes are upregulated both in the
epithelia and in the vlf fluid
so a duplication of this region
and the over representation of this
structural variation in our cohort
compared to the controls uh implicate
this structural variation
in severe covalent 19.
the the third common structural
variation
is a deletion of apobric genes
and these are the viral editing genes so
a loss of a viral editing gene
uh can be seen as
a formulation for the virus to evade the
viral editing or the immune response
again the again the loss was
confirmed in these patients with the
help of qpcr experiment
the the fourth common structural
variation is
an insertion in the promoter region of
mx1 gene which is a type 1 interferon
evolutionarily what we have seen that as
the
length of the five utr or the promoter
region
elongates it leads to reduced uh
transcription of the gene so
in rna-seq experiments and single-c
single cell rna-seq experiments in the
literature
almost uh all these lit literature
predominantly
finds that the mx1 is down regulated in
severely ill patients as compared to
population of controls
so an insertion in mx1 gene
and the over representation of this
structural variation in our cohort
compared to the controls uh is
words of an sp to follow up to
with uh expression analysis
and seems to be implicated in patients
with severe coherency
so i would like to conclude the
findings that the patient-centric
investigation identified 11 svs
involved in 38 genes implicated in three
key host viral interaction pathways
the first is innate immunity and
inflammatory response
the second is airway resistance to
pathogens which includes
muc4 gene and the third is viral
replication
spread in rla editing which includes the
epobec enzymes most importantly
we find that stk26 and bpp4 are the most
promising candidates
both based on the rarity of the
structural variation
and the expression analysis and the
support from the literature
and with the genetic analysis that is
coming on
from other jeevas experiments
these findings actually extend the
previous reports
that involve innate immunity and type 1
interferon response
in the pathogenesis of kobit 19
and most importantly we find that
optical genome mapping
is a powerful tool to identify large
structural variations
which must be documented uh to
investigate the
host genome uh to identify
the predisposition of or susceptibility
to severe
covalent 19 as we are looking at the
vast inter-individual variability
associated with
infection in patients infected with
sarcoma
to summarize we had uh put up this
schematic to represent different
pathways
and put out a holistic picture
to what we are seeing and
we actually have incorporated them major
structure variations
and you can uh see
the sdk 26 dpp4 zdhs c1
and a diminished response to type 1
interferons and
most of these players actually overlap
with different pathways
where as you can see that v dhs c1
uh translationally modifies if it
m3 but also uh down regulates the type
one interferon response and so on and so
forth
so with this i would like to acknowledge
uh
especially dr ravinder kohli for uh
leading this
study and the consortium dr ashish
mandel
who is our laboratory supervisor
dr alka chave and dr alex hasey at
bionicgenomics
dr rashmi kannagar shamna at md anderson
institute dr mike zodi from new york
genome center
dr eric jarvis from rockefeller
university
dr ellen banks and dr kathleen
baumscheen at harvard university
dr alexander horison at sandbone
university
ucsc dr bryan levy at columbia
university
and dr sylvia allen the canoe at
virginia commonwealth university
thank you so much for your attention
well thank you dr kolhay and nikhil
sahaj paul for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
let's see
sorry they're moving around people are
asking questions that's great okay
um why and how is the hypothesis of host
gm genome variations smps
svs is the crucial is is crucial for
severity of the disease
why not the viral genome variation
um can you can you hear me it is ravi
yes we can hear you okay so
when we looked at the disease biology i
mean
right from the january 2020 there were
multiple factors which are
playing a crucial role in determining
who is becoming symptomatic
who is becoming uh
oxygen dependent who is becoming icu
dependent and who is dying
and we looked at all possible aspects of
those things one of the biggest thing
was
yet not not even vital genome you can
talk about the wider load
the the biology will they say if you
have high viral load you should be
more symptomatic and need oxygen but
that was not true
uh when you looked at the original
the wuhan genome the b1 or the b
majority of the infections up to may
june maybe up to july or august were
with the original genome
and even with the original genome we saw
such a variation
in symptoms not only symptoms but uh
icu admissions oxygen dependence and
death
so we have a very crucial and
substantial evidence to show that
it's not the viral genome which dictate
majority of these split survival or
split symptoms
yes i agree i think viral genome will
definitely
play a role uh in the latter half but if
you look
at uh in the earlier part of the
pandemic i think
uh the host genome played a significant
role
and that's what we are trying to
understand
thank you dr colgate yes and our next
question
do you think we can infer which patients
will be severe in covet infection with
reference to skt
gene duplication in the utr region
so i would like to go with that uh
certainly the host genome structural
variations
especially the unique ones uh are the
ones which are to watch out for
and are the key ones that can predispose
to severe disease
and because we have only seen this
structural variation in one patient
and five utr region does lead to x
over expression of the gene so we can
certainly infer that because the stk26
pathway is already up regulated
a structural variation in that region
potentiates further
towards disease severity so this is what
we are inferring that
the the structural variation that we had
seen in stk26
is actually protein potentiating further
towards severity of the disease
thank you nikhil let's see with our next
question
um let's see what is the foremost gene
with svs which will
infer mostly for severity
uh so well i didn't hear the question
go ahead yeah so
the severity actually you have to see
patient by patient that is why the
analysis
is patient-centric so any of the
rare structural variations impacting or
disrupting a key gene
in the immune response can lead to
severity
so this investigation we have found that
uh stk 26 dpp 4 or zdhs c1
where stk26 and gdhc1 are type 1
interferon response pathway
but um pp4 is a different
uh in a different pathway so they need
not be in the same pathway or in the
same gene
like uh jivas investigations or
sequencing based
investigations have found loss in
function of tlr3 there are seven
genes so it all depends that what
it can be a different gene but if it
implicates in a key
immune gene or host response gene then
it will lead to
severity of the disease thank you
thank you michiel let's see our next
question can you see a clinical use for
these variants
can they be used when patients report to
the hospital with an infection or when
would they matter
so i mean definitely that that is the
primary goal of this i mean any research
or translational research we are trying
to do or understand
has to translate into clinical utilities
so the big picture goal or the bigger
goal for this
study is is there a way we can uh
identify structural variant create an
assay
maybe on a pcr or even optical genome
mapping and come up with uh some kind of
early warning
uh and then predict the outcome of these
individuals
so yes i think these structural venues
are definitely
critical and not just an immune response
but if you look at
any inherited genetic disease structural
obedience do play a critical role in
disease
uh in disease initiation and as well as
in response and mortality so no doubt
about that this experience will play a
critical role
i think what we are at the current stage
we are doing
is we are trying to come up with a
consensus on
which structural variants actually play
a significant role
enough for us to translate an assay
and i know there are groups and
collaborators in europe which have
already started working on
or already in the lab especially focused
on tlr7
based assets so the answer is yes
thank you dr colgate and we have another
question coming in
how can you tease apart whether it is
severe pathology causing the structural
variance
or it is the existing structural
variants causing severe copper pathology
i i think uh this has
i mean if you look at this is a viral
infection
i really hope the vital is not the vital
infection of the virus is not causing
any structural changes in our genome
because that itself will be a whole
different discovery and research
based on our existing knowledge our
collective knowledge and vital infection
i mean if you look at influenza
retrovirus like hiv there is definitely
some damage to the genome by
genome integration from these viruses
but i would like to
comfortably say that
the the response to the virus is
different based on the structural
variance rather than the virus
is causing any changes in our structural
variance and i mean i'm open to
discussion and ideas
but as far as we know collectively for
last
few years a few decades we're working
with viruses i think
it's usually the other way around thank
you
thank you and our next question
you showed several somewhat common
variants including some
only in african americans you also
showed how african americans are more
likely to be
severely affected is it possible that
some of those common variants you
identified may predispose
african americans to this more severe
infection
exactly yeah yeah
all right okay
exactly so what we have seen that the
common such
variations are actually over represented
in our data because we are
focused on the severely ill and we have
actually written this in our manuscript
that
because these common structural
variations
are also over represented in the african
american population
and we have seen and uh
a higher susceptibility of
african-american population to
severe cocaine 19. these might be the
common structure variations might be
a factor that is leading to higher
civility in this
specific population so so the
the question already actually answered
that yes
it is uh it is implicated it seems to be
implicated
yeah and then the other thing i want to
add to nikhil's discussion is
we we are in that part of the georgia
where we are
heavily dominated by african-american
population and when we looked at
the number of admissions on a 100
caucasian versus 100 african-americans
in our
hospitals in icu especially focused on
south
georgia we have identified that the
mortality as well as
the mobility rate for covet-related
infection was
surprisingly higher in african-american
population and i think that was one of
the reasons
we initiated his study was to identify
if there was something which was very
specific
for the african-american population
which is uh
have a higher burden of uh mobility and
mortality associated with that disease
so again this is a
this data and the study is at very early
stage we would
we we are increasing our study
population and
as well as the control database and
referee at some point
in the near future we'll be able to have
a solid conclusion on that but the
initial data
definitely looks uh in that direction
thank you
okay thank you both we have a good
question do you see a point in the
future where this technology will be
applied to examine treatment resistance
and clinical trials
uh seems very well suited to answer the
basic question of was it the treatment
or the target
that is causing treatments resistance to
targeted therapies
so i i would say all of them because i
mean the technology
is just a way to identify
aberrations whether it can be related to
the disease generation or
a target for the disease or even in
on therapy response to identify
resistance or relapse to the therapy
i think not only in inherited
or constitutional disorders you're going
to see a lot of
this technology will show up in
identifying the cause of
those diseases but when we come to
oncology
it is going to find a lot of new
discovery
in oncogenes especially
in comparison to the existing
platforms we are using for oncology
testing or karyotype and phishing arrays
which definitely have some
serial limitation and in in those cases
a platform like optical genome mapping
is going to make fundamental difference
in
our understanding for oncogenesis and
once you identify which is a common
denominator for a certain
phenotype then people will jump on
identifying therapies for those targets
and in the other group which the
question was asking about the
[Music]
resistance aspect i think that's
definitely
when we start looking or dissecting
cancers which are on therapy and
non-responsive and identify
new targets and in that subgroup also i
think optical genome mapping
is going to make pretty severe infos for
us to understand that disease
thank you
all right thank you dr colgate we have
one uh time for one final question
for stk26 the case with the sv
uh has the highest expression for dpp
for the case that the sv has the lowest
expression but in both cases you see
almost all the severely ill
differ from the asymptomatic doesn't
that argue against the sv being causal
if the change in expression is present
in anyone who is sick
so again uh we can look it
like this or the other way around so the
other way around is
that the structure variation led us to
the
investigation of identifying this
pathway and we found that
this pathway is actually implicated in
severe
severely ill patients but as we can see
that
the the patient with the structural
variations are the ones with the highest
or the lowest levels which shows that
although the pathway is implicated the
structural variation actually
potentiates
towards severity so this is where
it predisposes to severe disease
thank you
thank you all right well thank you both
dr coy did you have anything to add or
would you like me to
wrap up no i think i agree with nikhil
on that
but definitely it was a good discussion
overall
and i would like to thank your group for
helping us put this thing together we
had some initial technical difficulties
but i think this was a great discussion
on
a very uh pressing topic uh on the
pandemic
thank you all thank you i'm sorry i
thought you had something
there to add uh you know to answer that
question so um
you do either of you uh dr kulhay or
nikhil sahaj paul do you have any final
comments for our audience
aside from what you just said
i think you guys have done a great job
this is a this is a very
pressing topic and i'd like to thank the
binance folks for
helping us put this thing together alki
and alex and
will so thank you and now if there's any
additional questions we will be happy to
answer by email i think both
our emails are in the presentation
well thank you again dr colgate and uh
nikhil asaj paul for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank
labruz and our sponsor bionano genomics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye